bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Peter Singer
Peter Singer est un philosophe
australien contemporain il est
spécialiste de la question éthique plus
particulièrement de la question
bioéthique c'est-à-dire de l'éthique
appliquée au vivant
et Peter Singer est connu pour certaines
de ses positions qu'on peut aisément
qualifier de position controversées par
exemple Peter Singer est favorable à
l'euthanasie
il est également favorable à l'eugénisme
et il est en même temps un fervent
militant de la cause animale
on lui doit ce qui est devenu un livre
de référence en matière de droit des
animaux à savoir la libération animale
publiée en 1975
1975 c'est-à-dire il y a un demi-siècle
et depuis l'influence de Peter Singer
dans les débats éthiques internationaux
n'a cessé d'augmenter
alors qu'est-ce qui fait que les
positions de Peter Singer suscitent
autant de réactions qu'est-ce qui fait
que ces positions ont pu choquer
l'opinion publique et bien ça vient du
fait que la pensée philosophique de
Peter Singer est une pensée radicale
au sens étymologique c'est une pensée
qui prend les choses à la racine
et qui ne s'encombre pas des précautions
d'usage
une précaution d'usage ce serait dire
par exemple que la vie d'un nouveau-né a
plus de valeur que celle d'un animal
quelque chose sur quoi presque tout le
monde est d'accord
et bien non singer n'est pas d'accord
avec ça
il n'est pas d'accord et il entend bien
nous expliquer pourquoi
donc dans cet épisode on va expliquer
pourquoi Peter Singer n'est pas d'accord
avec ça on va expliquer quelle est sa
logique de raisonnement
quel est son épistémologie morale
et à l'issue de cette explication qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas avec ses
conclusions on comprendra un peu mieux
qu'elle regarde Peter Singer porte sur
l'être humain qu'elle regarde il porte
sur l'animal et sur la manière dont nous
devrions nous comporter à leur égard
alors on va commencer par le
commencement Peter Singer est un
utilitariste
utilitariste ça veut dire que pour lui
le seul et unique critère qui doit
entrer en ligne de compte dans
l'évaluation morale d'une action c'est
son utilité
sauf que utilité ici ça a un sens bien
particulier
ce que les utilitaristes appellent
l'utilité c'est la quantité de bonheur
global qu'une action est susceptible de
produire
donc on ne parle pas d'utilité au sens
où on dit par exemple qu'un marteau est
utile pour planter un clou
ou qu'une bouteille d'eau est utile pour
se désaltérer
on parle d'utilité en termes de bonheur
alors quand on dit bonheur il faut pas
se focaliser sur le mot
parce que selon les auteurs et selon les
traductions on trouvera des variantes
on trouvera bonheur mais on trouvera
également bien-être ou plaisir
pour les utilitaristes bonheur plaisir
bien-être tout ça ça revient au même
ça c'est une première chose
la deuxième chose c'est de comprendre en
quoi ce critère du bonheur
constitue le seul et unique critère qui
doit prévaloir dans l'évaluation morale
d'une action
tout vient de Jérémy Bentham
Jérémy mandat qui était un philosophe et
juriste britannique du 18e siècle et qui
disait je cite la nature a placé
l'humanité sous le gouvernement de 2
mètres souverains la douleur et le
plaisir
c'est à eux seul qui appartient de
signifier ce que nous devrions faire
comme de déterminer ce que nous ferons
fin de citation
autrement dit ce qui fait qu'une action
est moralement bonne ce n'est pas le
fait qu'elle soit conforme à une
certaine idée du bien
ou à certaines valeurs morales
considérées comme bonnes
exemple de valeur morale considérée
comme bonne le fait de ne pas mentir
le fait de ne pas voler de ne pas tuer
vous aurez remarqué les prescriptions
morales sont souvent des Antilles
prescriptions
elle ne nous disent pas tant ce qu'il
faut faire que ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire
le modèle du genre c'est les dix
commandements
les dix commandements que nous
continuons de respecter y compris dans
nos sociétés laïques
donc toujours est-il que dans la morale
disons classique on définit la valeur
d'une action à sa conformité à certains
principes
à certaines valeurs
et bien ce que nous disent les
utilitaristes c'est que cette manière de
voir c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi parce que à quoi
servent ces principes au fond
si on y réfléchit bien qu'est-ce qui
fait que ces valeurs morales sont perçus
comme bonnes
elles sont perçues comme bonnes tout
simplement parce que si on les applique
l'humanité sera plus heureuse
c'est ça que nous dit Madame
et suivez bien son raisonnement parce
que c'est vraiment pas absurde d'un
thème nous dit nous avons adopté des
valeurs morales non pas parce qu'elle
serait bonne en soi mais parce qu'elles
sont bénéfiques
bénéfiques en termes de bonheur
en termes de maximisation du bonheur
elles permettent à l'humanité de pouvoir
vivre de manière plus harmonieuse
plus pacifique
plus heureuse
donc c'est ça l'origine profonde de nos
valeurs morales
le désir d'être heureux
le désir inscrit en l'homme d'être
heureux
le besoin d'aller vers ce qui nous
procure du plaisir
le besoin de fuir ce qui lui cause de la
douleur
et c'est tout
le reste c'est de la construction
intellectuelle
c'est de l'artifice
les êtres humains ont créé les valeurs
morales qui justifie est facilite leur
poursuite du bonheur
vous avez plus de chances d'être heureux
si une règle morale interdire votre
voisin de venir vous tuer
ou de vous voler vos biens
alors la morale ne suffit pas toujours
d'où la deuxième couche que constitue la
loi et le déclenchement de la force
publique si elle est empreinte
mais fondamentalement nous dit Madame il
ne faut pas les chercher ailleurs
l'origine des valeurs morales
l'origine des valeurs morales c'est la
quête du bonheur
et la quête du bonheur elle se traduit
au quotidien par la recherche du plaisir
et par l'évitement de la douleur
donc ce que fait l'utilitarisme c'est
juste remettre les choses dans l'ordre
la morale ne vient pas d'en haut
elle vient d'en bas
la morale n'a pas une origine divine
elle n'a pas une origine transcendante
elle a une origine matérielle
une origine physiologique
et la création des valeurs morales ce
n'est rien d'autre que
l'institutionnalisation d'un intérêt
physiologique
notre corps nous pousse vers le plaisir
il nous pousse vers la recherche du
bonheur et nos valeurs morales viennent
donner un vernis sacré à cette impulsion
mais fondamentalement nos valeurs
morales sont arbitraires
dire que nos valeurs morales sont
arbitraires ce n'est pas dire qu'elles
n'ont pas de raison d'être
elles ont une raison d'être
une raison physiologique
mais ce qu'elles n'ont pas c'est une
origine sacrée
les valeurs morales ne sont pas sacrées
et donc elles ne sont pas des absolus
elles ne sont pas des entités flottantes
qui existaient indépendamment de nos
conventions
disons le très clairement
pour les utilitairesistes le bien
n'existe pas
il n'existe pas parce que c'est nous qui
le faisons exister
nous le faisons exister collectivement
mais indépendamment de nous
indépendamment des êtres humains qui
pensent et qui fabriquent la morale
cette morale n'existe pas
donc si nos valeurs morales ne sont pas
des absolus ça veut dire que ce qui
compte moralement parlant ce n'est pas
de respecter ses valeurs
ce qui compte c'est de produire les
effets recherchés par le respect de ses
valeurs
ce qui compte ce n'est pas l'idée du
bien
c'est d'agir de sorte à produire les
résultats que l'application de cette
idée du bien est censée générer
l'utilitarisme est un conséquentialisme
l'important n'est pas de respecter telle
ou tel principe
l'important est d'en produire les effets
c'est la seule chose qui compte
et ça peut se défendre comme idée
l'idée que s'il existe des règles c'est
pour parvenir à un certain résultat
et que donc l'important n'est pas tant
la règle que le résultat de la règle
et bien ce que font les utilitaristes
c'est qu'il retire la règle et qui nous
disent la seule règle c'est de maximiser
le bonheur
rappelez-vous ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure pour les utilitaristes nos
valeurs morales n'ont été créés que pour
satisfaire notre quête du bonheur
par conséquent on en fera pas la morale
en enfreignant les valeurs
on en fera la morale en enfreignant les
conséquences recherchées par ces valeurs
on en fera la morale quand notre action
débouche sur des conséquences négatives
en termes de bonheur
et c'est on de comprendre en quoi cette
position nous heurte
parce qu'elle donne l'impression d'une
morale à la carte
d'une morale permissive
l'idée que finalement tout serait permis
à condition que ça produise du bonheur à
l'arrivée
ben oui
c'est exactement ça la position
utilitariste
tout est permis du moment que ça
produise la quantité maximale de bonheur
global
c'est ça le critère
il y en a pas d'autres
mais attention encore faut-il que nos
actions débouchent effectivement sur une
maximisation du bonheur
parce qu'en réalité elle est là la
difficulté
la difficulté c'est qu'à chaque fois que
j'agis je dois me demander si mon action
contribue à la maximisation du bonheur
et ça c'est pas évident
parce que ça veut dire qu'avant d'agir
je dois faire calcul
un calcul pour déterminer non seulement
si mon action est porteuse d'une
augmentation de bonheur mais même si une
autre action ne serait pas porteuse
d'une plus grande augmentation
donc ça peut vite devenir un casse-tête
d'autant qu'on ne parle pas seulement de
bonheur individuel
on parle de bonheur global
la quantité globale de bonheur
donc dans certains cas il faudra se
demander si le sacrifice de mon propre
bonheur ne permettrait pas de créer un
plus grand bonheur global
aussi au contraire ce ne serait pas le
fait de privilégier mon propre bonheur
qui permettrait d'augmenter ce bonheur
global
pour les utilisaristes être égoïste
n'est pas mauvais en soi
ce n'est mauvais que si ça produit plus
de malheur globale que de bonheur global
l'éthique utilitariste est une éthique
du calcul
une arythme éthique
donc si on veut bien comprendre la
nature de l'utilitarisme
il faut se défaire de nos habitudes
morales
et de ce qu'on considère comme étant la
vraie morale
pour nous la vraie morale c'est de
respecter des principes
de les respecter indépendamment des
conséquences
quelle que soit les conséquences
en cela nous sommes tous conscients
on respecte la loi morale parce qu'elle
est la loi morale
ce que nous disent les utilitaristes
c'est que notre vrai moral est une
fausse morale
que la vraie morale c'est celle qui se
veut efficace
et une morale efficace c'est une morale
qui se soucie d'abord des conséquences
de nos actions en termes de bonheur
le reste comme dirait Bentham ce sont
des absurdités montées sur des échasses
ce sont des fictions
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à la
position de Peter Singer sur le tanasie
pour singer
l'euthanasie devrait être autorisé
je rappelle que euthanasie et où
Thanatos ça veut dire la bonne mort
la mort douce
celle qui soulage
est favorable à l'euthanasie
mais ce qu'on parle de l'euthanasie
volontaire
ce qu'on appelle le suicide assisté
c'est-à-dire l'euthanasie réclamé par le
patient
où est-ce qu'on parle de l'euthanasie
non volontaire
le fait comme on dit vulgairement de
débrancher un mourant pour abréger ses
souffrances
et bien les deux
Singer est favorable à l'euthanasie
volontaire et à l'euthanasie non
volontaire
parce que dans les deux cas le critère
est le même
le critère c'est la maximisation du
bonheur
est-ce que l'euthanasie d'un patient
gravement malade produirait plus de
bonheur que de malheur
si la réponse est oui alors il faut le
faire
autrement dit si le patient souffre et
que ses proches souffrent de le voir
dans cet état
alors il n'y a pas hésité
alors oui c'est proche vont également
souffrir quand ils vont apprendre son
décès
mais ce sera une souffrance temporaire
il s'en mettront
et le patient lui ne souffrira plus du
tout
donc à choisir entre une souffrance
indéfinie des proches et du patient et
une souffrance temporaire des proches
uniquement
le choix est vidu
alors vous allez me dire c'est quand
même grave
parce que là Singer est quand même en
train de légitimer le meurtre
l'euthanasie non volontaire c'est un
meurtre vu que le patient n'est pas
consentant
et bien oui
singer légitime le meurtre
un certain type de meurtre
et si vous êtes choqué par cette
position c'est que vous n'avez pas bien
écouté ce qu'on dit depuis tout à
l'heure
qu'est-ce qu'on dit depuis tout à
on dit que pour les utilitaristes la
question n'est pas de savoir si mon
action est conforme ou non aux valeurs
instituées
la question est de savoir est-ce que mon
action va dans le sens d'une
maximisation du bonheur global
je vais dire autrement
pour les utilitaristes il n'y a pas de
caractère sacré de la vie humaine
il y a du bonheur et de la souffrance
et la vie de valeur qu'en tant qu'elle
est un moyen d'éprouver du bonheur
mais une vie faite de souffrance
quelle est sa valeur
est-ce qu'il faut célébrer la vie
uniquement parce qu'elle est la vie
quand dans les faits cette vie n'est
faite que de souffrance
est-ce qu'il faut se convaincre qu'une
vie voit la peine d'être vécue
simplement parce que la morale nous dit
que la vie est sacrée
c'est ça que nous dit
donc en matière de questionnement moral
la réponse d'un utilitariste sera
toujours la même
est-ce que oui ou non mon action
contribue à la maximisation du bonheur
est-ce que oui ou non mon action est
plus susceptible de créer du bien-être
ou du mal-être
le reste n'a aucune importance
si vous demandez à un utilitariste s'il
vaut mieux un mensonge qui rend heureux
ou une vérité qui rend malheureux
il vous répondra sans hésiter un
mensonge qui rend heureux
et il ajoutera parce qu'il voudra être
sûr que vous ayez bien compris sa
réponse
à condition qu'on soit bien sûr que ce
mensonge produira effectivement plus de
bonheur que de malheur
parce que n'oublions pas qu'un mensonge
ça peut être découvert
et que quand on découvre qu'on nous a
menti ça rend malheureux
donc il faut en tenir compte
il faut tenir compte de tous les
paramètres
mais si on a bien pris en compte tous
les paramètres et que le résultat du
calcul c'est que le mensonge en question
produira plus de bonheur que de malheur
alors il est justifié
même chose pour la dignité humaine
la dignité humaine c'est un concept
c'est une abstraction qui n'a pas de
valeur en dehors de ce qu'elle implique
en terme de bonheur ou de malheur
quand on dit que je ne respecte pas la
dignité de quelqu'un en le maltraitant
ou en l'humiliant
ce que ça veut dire c'est que j'a moins
de ris son bonheur d'une manière
injustifiée
ce serait justifié si cette diminution
du bonheur avait pour conséquence une
augmentation de la quantité globale de
bonheur
mais quand ce n'est pas le cas alors ce
n'est pas justifié
donc ce n'est pas une question de
dignité
c'est une question de quantité de
bonheur
pour en revenir à l'euthanasie ce que
nous dit Peter Singer c'est qu'un
patient qui décide lui-même de mettre
fin à ses jours ou un patient auquel on
se substitue pour décider qui doit
mourir
dans les deux cas ce qui compte c'est de
savoir est-ce que oui ou non ça va
augmenter la quantité globale de bonheur
donc vous voyez que ce n'est pas le
critère de la liberté individuelle qui
importe ici
ce n'est pas le critère du consentement
plus exactement le consentement n'est
qu'un paramètre parmi d'autres du
bonheur global
là encore c'est le même raisonnement
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on est attaché à
la liberté qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on
considère la liberté comme une valeur
fondamentale c'est tout simplement le
fait que de manière générale on est plus
heureux quand on est libre
on a fait la liberté une valeur morale
suprême mais en réalité c'est le bonheur
associé à cette liberté qui nous l'a
fait considérer comme une valeur
importante
donc si le maintien en vide d'un malade
produit davantage de malheur que de
bonheur même si le patient n'est pas
consentant et bien il faut accepter
l'idée que l'euthanasie et la meilleure
option morale
et si vous répondez à Peter Singer que
nous ne sommes pas des machines
que la vie c'est pas juste un calcul
c'est pas juste une soustraction entre
la somme de bonheur et la somme de
souffrance
que nous sommes aussi des êtres
d'émotion et de sentiments
Peter Singer vous répondra oui
effectivement
la vie ce n'est pas qu'un calcul
la vie ce sont aussi des sentiments et
des émotions
mais sauf que ces sentiments et ses
émotions bien souvent c'est ce qui
perturbe notre jugement
c'est ce qui perturbe nos jugements
éthiques
et donc nos choix éthiques
l'émotion c'est ce qui fait qu'au lieu
de donner 100 euros à une association
qui pourrait fournir sans repas gratuit
à des nécessiteux
on va donner 100 euros à une association
qui permet à des enfants de réaliser
leurs rêves
c'est tout le propos du dernier livre de
Peter Singer l'altruisme efficace dans
lequel singer explique que quand nous
faisons preuve d'altruisme une
réfléchissons pas à l'efficacité de
notre altruisme
donc la vie n'est pas un calcul mais
l'éthique est un calcul
un calcul permanent
singer n'exclut pas le sentiment de la
vie
il ne l'exclut même pas de la situation
morale
il l'exclut du calcul moral
il exclut de l'opération rationnelle qui
consiste à établir si une action produit
plus de bonheur ou plus de malheur
cette opération intègre des sentiments
elle intègre la tristesse la compassion
l'espoir
mais le calcul en lui-même lui est
indépendant du sentiment
on ne demande pas à un comptable de
faire des sentiments
on lui demande de faire un bilan
positif ou négatif
addition et soustraction
et bien dès lors que nous devenons des
agents moraux c'est à dire dès lors que
nous agissons
nous devons devenir les comptables des
conséquences de nos actes
des comptables rigoureux
détachés de nos affects
au fond c'est ça le grand paradoxe de
l'utilitarisme de Peter Singer
à savoir que c'est au nom de la
maximisation du bonheur
c'est au nom de l'altruisme
qu'il faut être capable de ne pas faire
de sentiments
si vous êtes toujours choqué à ce stade
de la réflexion
sachez que vous n'avez pas encore tout
vu
Peter Singer et favorable à l'euthanasie
mais il est aussi favorable à
l'infanticide
dans certains cas particuliers
dans les cas où le nouveau-né est
atteint d'une maladie particulièrement
grave
d'une maladie qui le condamne à court
terme ou qui est source d'une souffrance
intolérable
quel est son raisonnement
son raisonnement est de dire que de la
même façon qu'on accepte qu'une femme
avorte si son enfant est porteur d'une
maladie grave quand je dis qu'on
l'accepte vous avez compris que je parle
de la législation dans la plupart des
pays occidentaux
donc de la même façon qu'on accepte
qu'une femme puisse tuer son enfant à
l'intérieur de son ventre
on devrait accepter qu'elle puisse le
tuer à l'extérieur de son ventre
et alors là vous allez dire mais enfin
il est malade
ça n'a absolument rien à voir
une femme qui avorte elle avorte d'un
embryon
pas d'un enfant déjà formé
tu es son enfant après qu'il soit né
c'est pas comparable avec tuer un
embryon
un embryon n'est pas une personne
un nouveau-né est une personne
et bien pour Peter Singer
non
un nouveau-né n'est pas une personne
et par conséquent la vie d'un nouveau-né
n'a pas plus de valeur que la vie d'un
embryon
je vous avais dit qu'on en avait pas
fini avec les propos choquants
donc maintenant il faut expliquer
Peter Singer et pour le droit à
l'avortement
on s'en serait douté
c'est cohérent avec sa vision globale
et ce qui est intéressant c'est la
manière dont il réfute les arguments des
anti-avortement
et vous allez voir que son analyse est
assez inattention
cette analyse on la trouve dans un livre
qui s'intitule question d'éthique
pratiques publiées en 1979
et singer nous dit voici comment résonne
ceux qui s'opposent au droit à
l'avortement
le raisonnement consiste à dire
il est mal de tuer un être humain or un
embryon est un être humain
conclusion il est mal de tuer un embryon
autrement dit ce que nous dit singer
c'est que l'argument des anti
avortements consiste à
identifier l'embryon à un être humain
c'est là-dessus qu'il s'appuie
les religieux diront par exemple qu'au
moment de la conception
l'embryon possède déjà une âme
et chez les non religieux l'argument
consiste à dire que même si l'embryon
n'est pas une personne il est une
personne potentielle
et que tu es une personne potentielle ce
n'est pas loin d'être aussi grave que de
tuer une personne tout court
et donc la réponse des pros avortement
c'est de dire que non
l'embryon n'est pas une personne
il n'est pas une personne parce qu'il
n'a pas encore les attributs
physiologiques qui font de lui une
personne
il n'est pas une personne parce qu'il
n'est pas encore viable
donc tu es un embryon n'est pas
équivalent d'un point de vue moral as-tu
un nouveau-né
alors singer ne s'attarde pas sur la
question de savoir à partir de quel
délai un embryon devient une personne
c'est une question très compliquée et
rien qu'en Europe tous les pays ne sont
pas d'accord entre eux
entre la Pologne ou l'avortement est
totalement interdit sauf qu'à
particulier et les Pays-Bas où il est
autorisé sans condition jusqu'à 5 mois
et demi
on voit bien que les opinions diffèrent
mais singer lui montre pas dans ce débat
là
parce que pour lui c'est pas ça qui
compte
pour lui ce qui compte c'est de se
demander quand bien même un embryon
serait effectivement un être humain
en quoi serait-il moralement condamnable
de tuer un être humain
autrement dit ce que critique Peter
Singer dans l'argumentation des
anti-avortement ce n'est pas la deuxième
prémisse
l'embryon est un être humain
ce qu'il critique c'est la première
prémisse à savoir
il est mal de tuer un être humain
ce qui doit être remis en question selon
singer c'est le fait que tu es un être
humain serait nécessairement mal
pourquoi ce serait nécessairement mal
parce qu'on l'a décrété
parce que c'est écrit dans les dix
commandements
parce que la vie humaine a un caractère
sacré
mais pourquoi la vie humaine serait-elle
sacrée
pourquoi la vie humaine spécifiquement
pourquoi la vie d'un chien ne serait pas
sacré
pourquoi la vie d'une vache ne serait
pas sacrée
ou celle d'un pigeon ou d'un pingouin
la réponse est parce que l'être humain
définit ce qui est sacré et ce qu'il
n'est pas à partir d'un seul critère qui
est lui-même
la thèse de Seeger c'est que la valeur
d'une vie n'est pas liée à l'importance
que notre culture donne à cette vie
dans certains pays il est autorisé de
manger du chien
ou du chat
en France beaucoup trouve ça choquant
parce qu'en France un chien ou un chat
c'est un animal de compagnie
c'est même un membre de la famille
en Inde certaines vaches sont
considérées comme sacrées
et il est formellement interdit à
quiconque non seulement de consommer
leur viande mais même de les maltraiter
ou de les contraindre
c'est la scène de Tintin au Tibet ou le
capitaine Haddock veut enjamber une
vache qui obstrue le passage et à qui un
passant va dire vous devez attendre
qu'elle décide de s'en aller
donc le point de vue sur le statut moral
des animaux dépend en grande partie de
la culture de notre pays
est-ce que ça démontre c'est que la
valeur morale qu'on accorde à une vie
est toujours arbitraire
elle dépend davantage des sentiments
qu'on investit dans cette vie que de sa
valeur objective
si tenté qu'on puisse parler d'une
valeur objective de la vie
j'en reviens au nouveau-né la question
que posinger c'est en quoi la vie d'un
nouveau-né
aurait-elle plus de valeur que la vie
d'un embryon ou d'un fœtus
en quoi la vie d'un nouveau-né
aurait-elle une valeur tout court
elle est là la vraie question
qu'est-ce qui donne de la valeur à une
vie
et bien c'est sur cette dernière
question que nous allons achever notre
réflexion
pour Peter Singer la première chose qui
donne de la valeur à une vie c'est la
capacité à éprouver du plaisir
c'est le critère de la sensibilité
non pas la sensibilité psychologique
la sensibilité comme capacité d'avoir
des sensations
autrement dit et pour que ce soit
concret une via de la valeur dans la
mesure où cette vie est porteuse de
plaisir
et je rappelle que pour les
utilitaristes plaisir bonheur ou bien
être servi en même
les plaisirs de la chair ne sont pas
dévalorisés par rapport au plaisir de
l'esprit
il n'y a pas de hiérarchie des plaisirs
il y a une hiérarchie de la quantité de
plaisir
est une philosophie qui quantifie
donc selon ce critère de la sensibilité
toute créature humaine ou non humaines
qui est en capacité d'éprouver du
plaisir
doit voir sa vie protégée
le seul cas où cette vie ne doit plus se
voir protéger
c'est quand elle est porteuse de plus de
souffrance que de bonheur
ce qui veut dire que pour singer la vie
d'un animal a de la valeur
tu as un animal c'est retiré un quantum
de bonheur du champ sensoriel universel
quand on mange de la viande animale nous
dit singer on génère un plaisir qui est
infiniment faible par rapport à la
souffrance qu'on a fait subir un animal
pour obtenir cette viande
manger de la viande n'est pas
condamnable au prétexte que la vie d'un
animal serait sacrée
la vie d'un animal n'est pas plus sacrée
ni moins sacré que la vie d'un être
humain
il s'agit pas de ça
manger de la viande et condamnable parce
que c'est un geste qui tend à augmenter
la souffrance globale
évitez de manger de la viande c'est
éviter de faire naître des animaux qui
souffriront inutilement
c'est-à-dire qui souffriront dans le
seul but de satisfaire nos désirs
et ce qui fait qu'on mange de la viande
sans se poser de questions c'est que
nous avons intégré l'idée d'une
infériorité du statut moral par rapport
au statut moral humain
pour la plupart d'entre nous si nous
avons le choix entre sauver la vie d'un
animal et sauver la vie d'un être humain
nous choisirons l'être humain
parce que nous avons intériorisé l'idée
que la vie d'un être humain avait plus
de valeur
raison pour laquelle le cannibalisme
ébani de la plupart des cultures
pourtant le cannibalisme c'est ce que
nous faisons avec des animaux non
humains
nous établissons une hiérarchie de la
valeur de la vie en fonction d'un
critère qui est l'appartenance à
l'espèce
Singer est un partisan de l'antispécisme
un terme qu'il a d'ailleurs largement
contribué à faire connaître du grand
public
le spécisme c'est l'équivalent du
racisme ou du sexisme mais pour les
espèces
c'est l'idée qu'il existerait une
hiérarchie des espèces et que l'être
humain se situerait au sommet de cette
hiérarchie
et si l'être humain se situe au sommet
de la hiérarchie ça veut dire que
l'homme serait autorisé à disposer de la
vie des espèces inférieures
c'est ça que compte singer
pour singer l'être humain est
effectivement supérieur à la plupart des
espèces sur le plan cognitif
mais pas sur le plan de la valeur de la
vie
on peut même dire que c'est parce que
l'être humain est supérieur sur le plan
cognitif qu'il a une responsabilité
morale vis-à-vis des autres espèces
quand le lion mange l'antilope il suit
son instinct
le Lion n'a pas la possibilité de se
poser la question morale
alors que l'homme a cette possibilité
quand un être humain tue un animal
inutilement ou quand il le fait souffrir
inutilement il fait quelque chose de mal
parce qu'il est conscient qu'il aurait
pu éviter cette souffrance
donc l'être humain est supérieur aux
autres espèces animales sur le plan
cognitif mais il ne leur est pas
supérieur sur le plan de la sensibilité
parce que l'animal comme l'être humain
est capable d'éprouver du plaisir et de
la douleur
et que dès lors qu'on se réfère à ce
critère de la sensibilité
animal et être humain sont égaux
ils sont au même niveau dans la
hiérarchie morale
la souffrance de l'un n'est pas
inférieure à la souffrance de l'autre
une souffrance égale une souffrance
être utile à risque c'est considérer
qu'il n'y a pas de souffrance qui soit
moins grave qu'une autre
et qu'il n'y a pas de bonheur qui soit
plus important qu'un autre
le principe prenez par singer c'est le
principe de l'égalité de considération
des intérêts
singer ne dit pas que tous les êtres
vivants ont le même intérêt à vivre
il dit que l'intérêt à vivre et le
critère sur lequel nous devons fonder
notre rapport aux êtres vivants
pour nous la vie d'une vache n'a que peu
d'intérêt
mais pour la vache sa vie c'est tout ce
qu'elle a
et sa vie a une valeur dans la mesure où
elle est porteuse de plaisir potentiels
le plaisir de la vache n'a pas moins de
valeur que le plaisir de l'être humain
mais vous aurez compris que cette idée a
des implications très lourdes
par exemple le fait que pour singer la
vie d'une personne qui a perdu son
aptitude au bonheur
ou qui n'a pas encore d'aptitude au
bonheur
cette vie là a moins de valeur
que la vie d'un animal apte au bonheur
la valeur d'une vie est proportionnelle
à sa capacité d'éprouver du bonheur
mais il y a un deuxième critère qui pour
singer permet de définir la valeur de la
vie
on parlait il y a quelques instants du
nouveau-né
et du fait que pour singer tu es un
nouveau-né n'était fondamentalement pas
plus grave que de tuer un fœtus ou un
embryon
pourquoi parce que le nouveau-né même
s'il peut éprouver du plaisir et de la
douleur n'est pas encore en capacité de
formuler des préférences
il n'est pas encore en capacité de
former ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
projet existentiel
en clair le nouveau-né n'a pas
conscience de la valeur de sa vie
et s'il n'a pas conscience de la valeur
de sa vie
perdre la vie n'a pas la même
signification pour lui que pour une
personne qui en a conscience
pour singer la valeur de la vie humaine
dépend étroitement de notre capacité à
avoir conscience de la valeur de notre
vie
c'est ce qu'il appelle avoir une vie
biographique et pas seulement biologique
avoir une vie biographique c'est être
capable de se projeter dans l'avenir
de s'imaginer au-delà de notre situation
présente
parce que clairement si notre vie a un
sens c'est parce qu'il nous est possible
de nous projeter dans l'avenir
d'avoir des envies des projets des
espoirs
et donc quand on supprime la vie d'un
être conscient quand on supprime la vie
d'un être capable de formuler des
préférences
on ne tue pas seulement une entité
biologique
on tue aussi ces espoirs
et ça ça compte
pour singer
ôtez la vie à un nouveau-né n'est pas
aussi condamnable côté la vie à une
personne
parce qu'aussi longtemps que l'enfant
n'est pas en mesure d'exprimer des
préférences
aussi longtemps que l'enfant n'est pas
en mesure de savoir ce qu'il veut
de surajouter à son existence biologique
une existence biographique
sa vie n'a pas autant de valeur que la
vie d'une personne
en résumé si la valeur de la vie dépend
d'abord de la capacité sensorielle à
éprouver du plaisir et de la douleur
la valeur de la vie humaine dépend en
plus de la capacité existentielle à se
projeter dans un avenir possible
je cite
ce qu'il faut c'est se demander quelle
capacité chez un être vivant son
moralement significatives la capacité de
ressentir du plaisir ou de la souffrance
me semble être une composante
essentielle de la réponse à l'évidence
elle n'est pas le propre de l'homme
prenez dès lors un principe moral que je
tiens pour fondamental celui de
l'égalité de considération des intérêts
ce principe doit s'appliquer à
l'ensemble des êtres possédant cette
capacité à souffrir quel que soit
l'espèce à laquelle ils appartiennent de
même que nous nous refusons aujourd'hui
à négliger les intérêts d'un être humain
en raison de son sexe ou de la couleur
de sa peau nous devons cesser de ne pas
prendre en compte les intérêts d'un être
vivant simplement parce qu'il n'est pas
de notre espèce je ne dis pas qu'un
babouin a le même intérêt à continuer à
vivre qu'un être humain cela dépend en
fait de l'être humain si ce dernier
possède le sens de son existence dans le
temps ce que j'appelle avoir une vie
biographique et pas seulement biologique
alors oui on peut dire que cet être
humain un plus grand intérêt à continuer
à vivre la doctrine du caractère sacré
de la vie humaine n'est plus défendable
c'est une doctrine profondément ancrée
dans la tradition judéo-chrétienne selon
laquelle l'être humain et lui seul
possède un statut moral spécial en
raison de ce statut privilégié enlevez
la vie à un être humain est en soit un
acte moralement condamnable quel que
soit les circonstances car toute vie
humaine est considérée comme d'égal
valeurs tuer un nouveau né handicapé
n'est pas équivalent d'un point de vue
moral a tué une personne très souvent il
n'y a là rien de mal ce jugement est
valable lorsque le nouveau-né présente
des handicaps tels que sa vie autant que
puissant juger ses parents ne pourra
être une vie satisfaisante mais ce n'est
pas moi qui vais vous spécifier quelle
vie est satisfaisante ou non ce jugement
appartient aux parents éventuellement en
concertation avec des médecins quant à
handicap détecté avant la naissance et
sévère on autorise l'avortement
l'embryon a juste titre n'est pas encore
considéré comme une personne pleine et
entière mais le nouveau-né peut-il être
davantage je ne le pense pas on doit
donc aussi autoriser de mettre un terme
à la vie d'un nouveau-né qu'on découvre
à la naissance ou peu après porteur d'un
fort handicap la phrase reste d'ailleurs
valable si vous enlevez le mot handicapé
je ne pense pas que tu es un nouveau-né
soit jamais équivalent à tuer une
personne par personne j'entends un être
capable de raison et possédant notamment
ce sens de son existence dans le temps
dont nous avons parlé cela étant dit la
question du passage de l'état de
nouveau-né à celui de personnes demeure
ce passage est bien évidemment
progressif mais on peut au moins
affirmer que dans le premier mois de son
existence un nouveau-né n'est pas une
personne un mois me semble donc un délai
raisonnable à accorder aux parents pour
décider si leur bébé doit continuer à
vivre
l'histoire de la pensée occidentale
est marqué par un éloignement progressif
à l'égard du sacré
plus nous avons gagné en connaissance je
parle ici des connaissances
scientifiques
plus nous avons délaissé les anciennes
notions métaphysiques
qui ne serait finalement que des
croyances sans fondement
les tiques à remplacé la morale
l'éthique c'est la morale moins la
métaphysique
c'est la morale moins le sacré
et à partir du moment où on abandonne le
sacré
on en arrive fatalement à la conclusion
que la vie elle-même n'est pas sacrée
dire que la vie ne vaut la peine d'être
vécue que si elle est porteuse de
plaisir
dire que la vie d'un nouveau-né ou celle
d'une personne handicapée à moins de
valeur que celle d'une personne apte au
bonheur
ce n'est pas dire quelque chose de
choquant
c'est simplement validé la mort du sacré
c'est aller dans le sens
d'une des spiritualisation du rapport à
la vie
une vie dont la valeur se réduit
désormais à l'intérêt
nous avons la morale de notre
métaphysique
et quand la métaphysique devient
physique
notre moral devient mathématique
une morale du calcul
nous devenons somme et produit
nous devenons pertes et profit
et notre vie devient une équation
dont l'intérêt et la solution
je vous remercie
[Musique]